hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number
201 that is the first live stream of our
second series of
200 that did not add a lot of
information but it sounded um I don't
know uh not poignant really but
momentous is what it sounded no I don't
think that either well I don't know any
any morning which you can use the word
both poignant and momentous is a pretty
good morning I would say even if you've
used them to indicate that neither
applies that's the technically I think
it still counts this is I mean this is
like what kids in fourth grade maybe 8th
grade maybe also 12th grade do when
asked to use a word to
sentence the word momentus is not
applicable here no it's it's slightly
better than that um this involved my
knowing the meaning oh I know that you
do yes I have for quite some time all
right um here we are evolutionary lens
live stream yes number 201 end of
November uh we are past Thanksgiving
heading into the rest of the holiday
season uh no Q&A today but we're going
to be talking about quarantine and
Penguins pretty much yeah quarantine and
Penguins not quaran we're not
quarantining Penguins the penguins are
not inflicting quarantine on anyone they
wouldn't do that no they would not no uh
but hey come join us on Rumble and on
locals we got our uh watch part going on
at locals right now we've got early
release of guest episodes of Darkhorse
at locals we got our private monthly Q&A
which we did last Sunday which is still
available there am's Discord server
available there come join us at locals
And subscribe on Rumble and um and
generally come be with us there also
we've got the store which Zach is going
to show where you can get stuff like I
don't even know I mean I do know but I
don't know what he's going to show
us it's uh
it's yeah blueberries because oxident
happen U yeah I wasn't really ready a
second well that worked yeah was a hint
of things that one might get if one fun
you get Dark Horse March you get shirts
hats hoodies Goliath Goliath nice nice
very good blueberries because accidents
happen we have YouTube Community
guidelines because you can't handle the
truth yeah man yeah um epic Tabby more
we got at least one more coming out
before uh before Christmas happens as
well I hope uh I'm getting worried face
from our producer but you know we hope
um and um we're not doing a Q&A this
week uh we will do after the after the
live stream next week we'll do like a
special like recommended gifts episode
and we're going to move the rest of our
announcements to the end except for our
ads yes yes wait
what and for the store right now we
still have our holiday discount going oh
holiday 10 is the code for 10% off
holiday 10 uh at at the store right now
for 10% off at Darkhorse store.org
correct awesome and as always we have
three ads to start the top of the hour
we are grateful to our sponsors we
choose them carefully uh and uh let's
just go you're first this week I am
first this week uh we are pleased to
have us our first sponsor the wellness
company world-renowned experts like Dr
Peter Mulla have partnered with the
wellness company to create real change
in healthcare they offer a wide variety
of supplements and services including
tah health emergency medical kits which
have I
and teams of medical professionals that
can assist in helping patients kick the
pharmaceutical habit with their freedom
from farmer program the wellness company
has all sorts of useful and important
products personally we are fans of Mido
support Mido as in mitochondria which is
formulated to provide energy both
physical and mental and their Spike
support formula is their most popular
product it's useful not only for those
who have been vaccinated but for anyone
who may be suffering from long covid as
well the wellness company says on their
website if you're looking to get back to
that pre-co feeling their Spike support
formula can help Spike support is made
with a combination of natural
ingredients like ninas dandelion root
extract selenium black sativa extract
Irish sea moss and green tea extract
these ingredients all contain immune
boosting capabilities and the nyas
specifically has been used by the
Japanese for decades because of its
ability to dissolve blood clots but more
recently ninas has been shown to be able
to break down proteins in the
bloodstream and even block them from
binding to cells Dr Mulla says out of
all available therapies I have used in
my practice and among all proposed
detoxification agents I believe ninas
and related peptides hold the greatest
promise whether you've taken the vaccine
or just had covid if you're concerned
about circulating Spike proteins go to
tww c. Health Darkhorse and use the code
Darkhorse to save 15% on your first
order that's tww c. Health Darkhorse
code Darkhorse to save
15% our second sponsor this week is
Hillsdale College time is our most
precious commodity and too much of our
time ends up wasted in Mindless activity
at Hillsdale College though there are
more than 40 free online courses to
choose from they're self-paced you can
start whenever you want and you can
start right now please wait until the
end of the podcast though it's
everything you need all in one place
with no long-term commitment excuse me
learn when and where you want
since 1844 Hillsdale College has been
providing an education that focuses on
freedom and character at Hillsdale they
believe that a virtual citizen is the
best defense for Liberty time and
Technology have changed a lot of things
but they have not changed basic
fundamental truths about the world and
our place in it Hillsdale College's
online courses range widely there are
several on the constitution on Congress
the presidency the Supreme Court there
are great books courses as well as
courses focusing on the works of CS
Lewis Mark Twain Shakespeare and Jane
Austin there are history classes from
ancient Christianity to the the rise and
fall the Roman Republic to the second
world war even classes on math and logic
from uclid to Modern geometry and one of
the great principles of chemistry one of
hillsdale's newest online courses is
American citizenship and its decline
with Victor Davis Hansen in this eight
lecture course Hansen explores the
history of citizenship in the west and
the threats it faces today threats like
the erosion of the middle class the
growth of an unaccountable deep State
The Disappearance of borders and the
rise of globalist organizations the
course is self-paced so you can start
whenever and wherever so start your free
course American citizenship and its
decline today go right now to
hillsdale.edu darkhour to start it's
free and easy to get started that's
hillsdale.edu dark Darkhorse once again
Hillsdale h l LS D e.edu
Darkhorse
excellent just the one word uh I was
actually at slightly distracted from
Hillsdale a marvelous institution by the
fear that I may have mispronounced Natok
KES but anyway I'm back
good our final sponsor this week is
seed no one else was
concerned it may be that everyone else
was concerned
Nyes
uh yes may be concerned they may well
have been they may be irate at this
point where's it from nines yeah I don't
know how's it how's it synthesized what
it like what what organism does it come
from well now you're putting me on the
spot I don't know um I mean if you're
going to mispronounce you got to know
something else about it to is that a
rule I think so I don't think that's a r
okay so uh we've heard from the wellness
about the wellness company in Hillsdale
College and now seed our final sponsor
this week is seed a probiotic that
really works if you've tried probiotics
before and got nothing out of it try
seed it's designed differently from
other probiotics better and it actually
works seed helps improve the health of
your gut microbiome which means that it
supports you becoming healthier overall
our resident gut microbes directly
impact the development and function of
the immune system even before before
we're born microbes inform our immune
system teaching our body how to
distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that substances that our body
doesn't recognize as its own you can
support your gut immune axis in a
variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes to your
normal rhythms can disrupt your microbes
and the important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune AIS healthy seeds
dsl1 daily symbiotic also supports your
gut immune axis seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards digestive
health and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin
Health seed is free from 14 major
classes of allergens including but not
limited to Sugar Animal product soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and corn and seed is basically Double H
with its capsule and capsule design
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it the same
design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary among other
things this means that you can travel
with it seed's daily symbiotic supports
gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis people who use
seed often report improvements to their
Justus a function in 24 to 48 hours so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 25% off your first
month of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse at checkout now have the folks
at seed considered using capsule my
capsule as a slogan you should ask them
I should ask them I should ask them um
yeah why do we talk about microbes but
we never talk about
macrobes
speechless well people talk about
macrobiotics yes they do but I was
thinking more like I mean it could
either refer to um you know tapeworms or
it could refer to things like pets
macrobes yeah I think this has sort of
been the spirit of um you know
conservation biology types um refer to
charismatic megap being the things that
Grace the logos of the big conservation
societies like I think Wildlife World
Wild World Wildlife Fund has a panda
maybe um I can't remember what I has or
WCS but anyway they tend to have you
know the big the charismatic MEAP the
Lions and the Tigers and the bears oh my
yes um and um I like to think about talk
about the car charismatic misana uh
which are things
like
margay uh yeah margay you think that
still qualifies as Mega oh that's Mega
when you think about margay is the
smallest of the five cats uh found at
least at tiputini in the Western in the
western Amazon inor is small for a cat
gigantic for an
animal still
miso yeah still I don't know that it's
gigantic for an animal I know I mean it
depends how we weight it if we do it by
a species it's clearly
gigantic
forette the huge majority being but are
most animals
charismatic see that that's the question
yeah this is this but it's not a miso
fauna it might be miso among the
charismatic fauna but yeah all right
we're now losing people I know that we
are driving them away and droves 100% we
droving them away I think is the way you
would say that so you want to talk about
quarantine which seems appropriate now
they seem to be avoiding it um yeah
let's talk about uh Zack do you want to
put up the um
the legal order
here the actual yeah so what has
happened here is the Supreme Court of
New York has reinstated rule
2.13 is it is it this that you want him
to
show um I want you to show the this is
the ruling of the court I want you to
show the order
itself there were two things like I
don't know which one you're talking is
it this that you want him to
show uh yes okay you can just show my
screen then or enlarge it if you
would so what this is is
a very tiny at the moment um this is a
provision now of New York state law that
has been reinstated a panel of Judges
had Struck it down
and I believe in this last week it has
been reinstated by the Supreme Court of
New York and what it applies to for
people who are just listening um section
2.13 isolation and quarantine procedures
state of New York uh effective April
22nd 2022 it was struck down and
November 17th of this year so a couple
weeks ago or a week and a half ago um it
was uh reinstated so the strike down was
struck down the strike down was struck
down on a basis that we will get to here
in a second but let's begin reading this
thing so people know what we're talking
about isolo
2.13 isolation and quarantine procedures
a duty to issue isolation and quarantine
orders A1 whenever appropriate to
control the spread of a highly
contagious communicable disease the
state Commissioner of Health May issue
and or may direct the local local health
authority to issue isolation and or
quarantine orders consistent with the
due process of law to all such persons
as the state Commissioner of Health
shall determine appropriate so let we
will continue here uh in a moment but I
just want to point out let's Steel Man
their position here so this is a set of
quarantine procedures that they are
laying out and these are things
necessary to control highly contagious
community unicable diseases so these are
frightening things they are nothing to
sneeze at they are things as dangerous
potentially as the common cold which
meets that definition I just want to
point out highly contagious communicable
disease so
this what they want you to do here I'm
now no longer steel Manning what they
want you to do here is mistake them for
being extremely concerned about very
dangerous diseases when the provision
that they have laid out here isn't about
very dangerous diseases it could
certainly include them but it also does
include these very same Powers even to
control the common cold now I find that
uh telling I think that they have
actually
telegraphed their desire to use these
control mechanisms by not actually
saying anything about dangerous
diseases um and I would point out that
the way that you would do that if you
were actually serious about controlling
dangerous diseases now mind you none of
these things uh these Provisions would
be justified even in the case of
dangerous diseases for reasons that we
can get to but the conflation in the
public mind just the same way you saw
the public was confused by lots of talk
of antibodies because the public knows
what an antibody is but it doesn't
really know what a T cell is this is
also the same thing by saying highly
contagious that sounds very frightening
what you want to look for is virulent
that's the term that says that something
is destructive highly contagious just
means it passes easily from one person
to another which is true of the common
cold which you certainly would not want
to see civil liberties overturned to
control it would be an absurdity and yet
they've given themselves that power okay
so your your objection uh your objection
to the language of the paragraph that we
just read and you might actually put it
back up Zack so people can see it again
this is
paragraph A1 um from this rule 2.13 that
was just reinstated in the state of New
York um it is about controlling the
spread of a quote highly contagious
communicable communicable disease and
your point is lots of things are highly
communicable uh but they don't matter
that much and uh there should be no
justification uh for uh invoking
emergency Powers uh simply for things
that are highly communicable that is the
wrong standard I would I would add what
I what struck me about this first
paragraph is the use not once but twice
of the term appropriate uh and uh I
believe that they do not go ahead to
Define appropriate um Below in fact they
continue to use it I see it
on well I'm looking at a different
screen than you guys are but I see it in
paragraph four as well so whenever
appropriate to control the spread of a
highly contagious communicable disease
and then um to ALS such persons as the
state Commissioner of Health shall
determine appropriate so we've got
appropriate which is entirely a
subjective assessment uh which uh I do
not know I don't know if you found uh
the basis by which this was struck down
in the first place um but we do know the
basis on which it was unstruck down this
last week and a half or so yes I believe
so we should dig deeper but I believe
that the reason it was struck down was
that it cleared c l um it clearly
challenged well-established civil rights
um in an inappropriate way it was
reestablished as you know uh on the
basis that the uh legislators Who
challenged it in court were deemed not
to have standing which is fascinating in
two different ways there a legal term
meaning wellan a legal um not a term a
standard yeah legal principle and the
idea is that you don't you
know I can't sue you for your breach of
contract uh with some third party right
so the idea is the court establishes
that somebody is actually deemed uh
harmed or jeopardized by some legal
statute so that that's unfortunately a
civil example but let's let's take the
case uh which I think is in some ways
parallel of the National Defense
authorization act 2012 which
instantiated a right to in indefinite
detention that the executive branch
could dictate that somebody was a threat
and have them hauled off any Street in
the world and detained indefinitely
without trial or the right to see a
lawyer any of these things until
hostilities end until the end of
hostilities and hostilities of course in
the war on terror how is there going to
be a moment where there's no more terror
so basically indefinite to the end of
time now the reason I raise it is
because Chris
Hedges and um gnome Chomsky actually
sued the Obama Administration over this
and were deemed to have standing on the
basis that at least Chris Hedges was in
Jeopardy because he had interviewed
members of al-Qaeda the way the
provision was written he was actually in
Jeopardy of being hauled off of any
Street in the world and detain one
degree of separation from established uh
terrorists or members of terrorist
organizations was sufficient to possibly
get you hold off a it wasn't even one
degree of separation there was a
vagueness I've forgotten the exact term
but it was something like uh you know
Aid to a terrorist organization helping
to publicize their existence exactly and
would point out as as people who've
watched previous podcasts um know there
is a special concern about anything that
the executive self defines it's one
thing um you know if you had this
provision we can haul anybody off of any
Street in the world but then a court
gets to review it but by the way that
the ndaa was structured no court could
review it in fact they didn't even have
to admit that they' they'd uh detained
you and likewise here there is
um um there is that same
self-referential executive move but if
we go back to the question of standing
so in the case of the ndaa Chris Hedges
was deemed to have standing on the basis
that he was in Jeopardy from the law in
question a three judge panel later uh
reversed it and reinstated the ndaa 2012
Provisions in question um now in this
case the legislators who sued to prevent
this uh this um provision from being
enacted had their rights as legislators
violated because this superseded this
was the executive taking power away from
the legislature to make law this was the
executive making law through its
executive powers rather than allowing
the legislature to do it so that was one
thing but
also these are
citizens they are legislators are
Citizens First legislators are citizens
and so they are also in Jeopardy of
having their freedom to associate uh
their Liberty um removed and when
determined to be appropriate right now
amazingly enough the court deemed that
they did not have standing which implies
not only that their right as legislators
to make law was somehow um
not even in legal question here but that
your that the harm done to you only
happens at the point that somebody
decides decides to exercise their
unconstitutional right to detain you
right so you're not harmed
um until the actual thing is invoked but
if somebody it's like
um
uh the court is failing to recognize
that taking a right the right to be free
and turning it into a privilege that is
to say you can only be free until we
decide you can't be free that that's not
a harm in and of itself as long as
you're still allowed to be free as long
as we're granting you the privilege to
be free it's as good as having the right
which is nonsense legally speaking right
um
so Okay so we've got a number of issues
we've got the question the
weird case of a court not seeming to
understand the most basic uh uh legal
structures and requirements and we have
what I'm arguing is not just the
language of the rule is bad the rule
would be bad even if it did say um uh
virulent diseases um the we've learned
you know again as I think we said last
week you should just simply run
everything that is being proposed
through the test of what would have
happened during covid if this provision
had been there um this is I mean we
haven't said it but this is patently
responsive to co so this comes out April
of 2022 a little more than just slightly
more than two years after lockdowns were
imposed uh in March of 2020 so you know
I don't think anyone is pretending that
this isn't precisely responsive to covid
and and therefore is imagined to be
something that uh the state of New York
anyway would have benefited from would
have would have behaved differently had
this been on the books um I I agree it
is obviously responsive to co uh the
fact that it is going to be instantiated
in law permanently without reference to
a particular disease we we have another
issue here which is so much of the
Tyranny that we've seen has to do with
the selective application of Standards
right it's double standards all the way
down and um the idea that the public
health authority of the state of New
York has the right to rob you of your
freedoms and literally have you detained
having committed no crime I would point
out uh also they don't have to
demonstrate that you're either sick or
have been exposed they have written this
in such a vague way um that it's when
deemed appropriate um and what that
means is that they can pick a disease
and they can decide that in this case
you need to be locked up exposed or not
sick or not um and then they can or it
for other diseases so we have this uh
obviously
inconsistent uh concern over um you know
over the spread of uh of pathogens right
we are obsessed over covid right um we
are not similarly obsessed over flu and
we are not at all obsessed over uh human
Poma virus right we're literally in
schools now teaching kids about uh sex
as if any uh reluctance about it is
misplaced H when in fact there's a
communicable disease that is transmitted
highly regularly that has a very dire
consequence which is uh cancer well I
would I would put a different spin on
HPV on the public health response to HPV
which is that once again like with
Co what we have is uh a recognized
pathogen a disease uh or condition uh
that is Downstream of that
pathogen and a solution that is created
by uh an you know Pharma uh that we are
told is the one and only way uh to
respond to the pathogen and and the
disease uh and so in the case of uh Co
obviously we have these these so-called
vaccines um um largely uh the MRNA
vaccines there were a few other options
available um but uh but largely what was
being pushed on everyone was Mna
vaccines and to reject those uh many of
us were told and still continue to be
told although I hear this less and less
and less now because most of the vaccine
enthusiasts have quietly stopped doing
their little boosters right um what we
were told was if you do not sign on to
our solution which is mRNA vaccines then
you do not believe in the problem that
we've identified which is a logical FY
that is so basic that a 2-year-old
should be able to figure it out same
thing with HPV I would say you are
saying the public health um
establishment doesn't recognize that HPV
is serious no I don't I don't think
that's true because they've got a
vaccine for it and they would have us
believe that is the only um not only
that it is effective but that it is safe
and it is the only thing that you can do
and they seem to then suggest that you
know once you've got that then you can
behave any way you want and so you know
the idea of behaviorally avoiding um or
in the case of covid like using you
lifestyle changes in terms of getting
outside and eating good food and
exercising and um and all of that will
perhaps uh bring your obesity and your
metabolic disease and you your diabetes
all under more control such that you are
less likely to be uh badly affected by
covid similarly with regard to HPV how
can you avoid exposure well you can
avoid exposure right you can avoid
exposure but um
the issue with HPV I agree with you that
the narrative is well there's a vaccine
that's how this is controlled right when
you look into that vaccine you discover
that it isn't such a simple
story uh there are significant health
risks there is a failure to stratify in
this case by uh sex um and maybe more to
the point and the reason that I raised
it without mentioning the vaccine is
that it has a limited cut coverage in
terms of the strains of HPV so I I am
not arguing that it's an appropriate
response at all yeah I that was not the
position that I was the position I'm
taking is they're not ignoring it they
have produced a solution that uh many of
us believe to be in fact an anti-s
solution um but this is how you know
this is not uh ignoring it uh on the
part of Public Health I'm sure there are
things that are being actively ignored
but this isn't one of them this is
another case of no no no we we've got
the solution for you right over here and
if you don't take the solution you know
what kind of monster are you anyway do
you want to kill grandma or in this case
uh young women right right but I guess
um I now see Public Health as two things
a lot of people that we know a lot of
covid dissidents are come from the
public health sector yeah um that said
public health is the perfect excuse to
go after uh civil
liberties um because the idea is well
medicine uh leaves something to be
desired with respect to how well it
treats over an entire population and as
I've said a dozen times in theory there
is a gap I no longer believe that this
system can be trusted to do anything
responsible with that Gap what it does
is it uses that Gap as an excuse and so
what we are left with is it you know the
coup of Public Health against medicine
has left you with terrible Medical Care
and an inability to trust your doctor
because they've been overridden by a
public health authority that coerces
them into saying things to you that
aren't accurate or helpful uh from your
perspective and it's not because public
health is so uh obsessed with protecting
the public that's just simply the fact
that there is something called Public
Health explains why you're overriding
doctors right so to to use uh a medical
pretext to override the normal law and
in fact I would point out that uh one of
the things that it says in the in the
law itself is that this will all be done
in accordance with due process but the
problem is um how exactly does that work
here for one thing you've just seen uh
an
egregious um failure of due process with
respect to whether or not the legal
provision itself is being treated uh
with proper skepticism by the court well
I actually I don't understand this so we
you read allow paragraph 1 paragraph 2
says paragraph one of the subdivision
shall not be construed as relieving the
authority and duty of local Health
authorities to issue isolation and
quarantine orders to control the spread
of a highly contagious communicable
disease consistent with due process of
law in the absence of such direction
from the state Commissioner of Health
yeah I think I may I maybe that's simple
and I'm just missing like I'm not
puzzled over it myself I think I know
what it says I think the idea is they
are giving the the commissioner the
right to pull individuals out of society
and lock them up for reasons having to
do with communicable disease the fact
that the commissioner has the right to
do that to individuals does not mean
that the system is relieved of the
responsibility to lock down the
population that this is not an
alternative to lockdowns that this is
some this is an addition to
lockdowns now consistent with due
process of law problem is they've set
out such a broad Authority here that
it's not even clear what that means and
I would point out that you know um yeah
I don't as as was the case with the FCC
uh rule changes that we covered last
week
the the provision here is written so
broadly that I couldn't even convince
myself that they couldn't pull a um
person exercising their right to speak
freely about their skepticism of either
uh the nature of a disease the
seriousness of it Etc and other words if
they deemed you if they if we run this
through the covid standard and they
deemed somebody you know like us guilty
of spreading misinformation for
suggesting that their vaccines might not
be perfectly safe or suggesting that the
disease self might be better treated by
uh a much safer alternative than the
vaccines whatever it's not obvious to me
that their excuse here doesn't work that
they couldn't quarantine you they
isolate you in some uh facility and they
they uh carve out a broad latitude in
terms of what an appropriate facility
they could quarantine you at home but
they can also not quarantine you at home
um they could deny you access to the
internet to keep you from jeopardizing
the public health in their mind and of
course all of this is wildly
unconstitutional and now here you have a
court saying um that the very people who
are best positioned to um make the
argument don't have standing to even
challenge it so you know it it's it's
it's the wish for more wishes it's um
the abuse of theories of executive power
that evade checks and balances it's all
of these things wrapped in
one well it feels um what you just said
about what this might
allow feels very similar to what the who
uh
addendum whatever it's called the the
new referendum the revisions to the
established rules that are going to be
voted on in May of 2024 um with regard
to expanding the scope of um what they
have access to and with the who it was
quite clear they actually um make it
fairly explicit whereas here when I
reread so you just said um could they
not use this to keep people like us uh
who are speaking about what a
communicable disease is how it transmits
who is most at risk whether or not the
proposed treatment is actually effective
could they not use this to stop us uh
from doing what we do and I think the
language is vague enough that that's
probably true once again paragraph one
which again you read already whenever
appropriate to control the spread of a
highly contagious communicable disease
the state Commissioner of Health May
issue and or may direct the local health
authority to issue isolation Andor
quarantine orders consistent with due
process of law to all such persons as
the state Commissioner of Health shall
determine appropriate to yeah that's the
phrase yeah to all such persons as the
Commissioner of Health May deem
appropriate that's rather complete
latitude to Define threats to Public
Health as uh as they would now I would
also all of these tricks need a name and
I don't have the name for this one yet
but there is some way of
writing a legal provision so that a
generous interpretation it's it's it's
the legal version of Martin Bailey a
generous interpretation you are supposed
to infer their intent from language
which suggests that their intent in this
case is to control very dangerous
diseases that may arise right whereas
the thing in question says nothing about
dangerous diseases it's not even in
there right so you're supposed to you're
supposed to impose that interpretation
and that is supposed to make anybody
who's like wait a minute do you see how
broad their latitude is sound like a
wild-eyed conspiracy theorist and the
point is that's even good if it slides
it by you know the court and the
legislature and then at some future date
some future Anthony fouchy decides to
invoke the uh aggressive meaning that
does not involve quarantining people
because they're sick it involves
quarantining people because they're a
threat to Public Health meaning Anthony
fouchy decides what information and
misinformation are and then convicts you
of it in private and then the next thing
you know you're being hauled off to
isolate you not from spreading a disease
but for spreading Insight on the
internet right yeah so that's what
courts are for and culture is highly
communicable so communicable yes it is
contagious even it is it is highly
contagious
but there's a reason when you go and you
look at a piece of law right it is not
written for the average person to just
simply understand what's being said it
is written in a tortured way legal is
tortured for a reason and yes that can
be used to skure things you know the um
the legal e that's at the end of the
documentation for some machine that
you've just bought that's dangerous
right that's designed to obscure your
understanding of your rights or maybe
even the hazards in question but in the
case of the law well-written law looks
like that because it is supposed to be
so precise that it cannot be abused by
somebody who decides they want to
evaporate your civil liberties and this
is the opposite and the courts are not
reacting to it like hey you call that
law right no we're striking that down
right it's the wrong people who made
this Rule and what's more the rule in
question is so broad here are 16 ways it
could be abused that do not uh appear to
have anything to do with controlling the
spread uh of an actually serious disease
so anyway that's the world we're living
in is like because the public is not in
a position to detect the lies it doesn't
matter how many experts can see the lies
because what we're going to default to
is the public inter interpretation and
the court is just sort of um going to
you know adhere to
that it does seem to be where we are
yeah
um
so uh I I would suggest that people read
up on this the lawyer who fought this
who just had her previous stay uh
overturned by the Supreme Court of New
York um is Bobby Anne flower Cox who has
written about this on her substack it
was republished by The Brownstone
Institute do you want to put that up
y so she
describes um the absurdity of this
ruling and goes through a series of
important questions that people are
likely to have in part which he
struggling with is that it is so hard to
imagine that a court actually let this
stand um that processing what that
implies is actually quite difficult and
so anyway she goes through it at length
I think it's definitely worth people's
time to read
it um anything else you want to say on
this topic all right well uh I I would
just say the one last thing is we are
now
seeing um tyrannical
modifications of the structures of
society moving out side of the normal
channels of um Ru making so that they
you know the FCC is working on some
change to its own authority Public
Health uh rules in New York are now
establishing blatantly unconstitutional
rights to um to sequester people for
whatever reason they they see fit the
hoon is now um going to uh be granted
the right to override National
sovereignty it's hard to even keep track
of all of the fronts on which the normal
rights that are supposed to be protected
um by our uh excellent
Constitution uh are being threatened so
I would say people need to start paying
attention to all of the little places
where these rights can be whittel away
um without it seeming like a big deal
because that's the mode that has been
adopted by whatever it is that has
chosen to go after our rights
well I think uh people are not aware of
it and when I don't know that it's it
doesn't seem like a big deal it's
there's just too much I can't pay
attention to everything so uh I think I
think many people have at this point
kind of thrown up their hands that like
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to pay attention to I don't I
don't know anymore right and I'm sure
that this this particular one uh will be
regarded um and you know I i' feel this
way a little bit myself like oh my god
well they it for the grace of God you
know if I if we were that sort of person
like I don't live in New York um
although the governor of New York is uh
you know on a par with the governor of
Washington state where we are so who
knows if it's coming down the same thing
is coming down the pike for us but you
know it feels like there's so much to
pay attention to uh that uh it's hard to
know where to turn well uh
um a couple things on that front one I
do see people discussing and I've
actually been hearing um discussions of
it for months now of people actually
moving out of New York precisely because
of this um well and people I mean people
have been fleeing New York since the
lockdowns yes and we've seen people flee
California for other
reasons the fact that or as well I'm not
sure about Washington but Oregon has a
net net loss U for the first time in a
long time this last year or two so the
fact that people are fleeing one
American state for another over changes
in law or the powers of the executive
branch in their state says that we're in
um a a frightening period of History I
would also say lots of things are
unclear about what it means that New
York is going to have these powers does
that mean that we have to Route flights
around New York if we're going to travel
somewhere and there's something
contentious in the public health space
and New York has carved out these rights
are we in Jeopardy just because you
don't want to fly through JFK yeah maybe
you don't so how extraordinary is it
that one even has to ask that question
in the United States of America in 2023
right that's a shocking question to have
to ask but there are so many of these
things where we've seen powers exercised
that are almost impossible to imagine
right from a perspective of 5 years ago
um
so somehow we we are decohering as a
nation to the extent that one has to
worry that uh some state has carved out
rights you know we saw this with uh with
um Reproductive Rights as well there's
concern about um where you happen to be
in the 50 states over major yep major
legal differences so um strange times I
do think there is a way in which people
are supposed to ignore this in part it's
because it's coming Fast and Furious at
all different levels but in part it's
also
because it is written so is to be boring
it is written so that a generous
interpretation makes it look like a uh
well-intentioned attempt to uh protect
us all and you have to read a little
further to understand that um if you
were trying to protect the public from
things that actually jeopardize it you
probably shouldn't have those rights in
this case but a well-intentioned attempt
would look different it would have some
sort of standard for the seriousness of
disease and there would be some way to
establish that we were going to treat
all diseases of that seriousness in the
same way and maybe we wouldn't establish
these rights in the case of diseases
that couldn't be controlled in these
manners right are you're going to
quarantine your way out of a highly
infectious uh respiratory virus right I
want to see a demonstration that that's
going to be
possible um but the point is what's
really going on here is an abuse of
power disguised as public health and we
all ought to get pretty good at spotting
that at this point having seen what we'
we've seen over the last several
years can we move to Penguins uh
Penguins is not a
place um penguins is an idea in the mind
it's a state of mind yes we or we can
move to that state of mind yes okay
actually first before we talk about
penguin specifically um let's talk a
little bit about the evolution of
sociality okay of of being social of the
condition of being social most organisms
most animals aren't
social but it evolves in many organisms
as you know especially in many mammal
and bird species under conditions where
being social and Cooperative in general
has adaptive value um
but to be social you have to be able to
recognize individuals and that's a
that's a little piece of the puzzle that
doesn't occur to people who haven't
thought about what it means to be social
under what conditions sociality might
evolve uh imagine U being social with
other human beings but not being able to
tell any of them apart like you know who
you are or maybe you know maybe you have
a sense of self maybe um but you can't
tell any of the individuals apart uh
you're not really going to be able to be
social you can aggregate you can end up
you you know clustering together and
maybe you know being together as you
know a bunch of fish when a tuna or
shark comes by that wants to eat you um
but those aggregations are not social
they're um they're clumping they're um
but but not social so you need to be
able to recognize individuals in order
for sociality to
evolve and um we tend to take this for
granted although even in humans there
are jokes about this right and they're
no longer considered acceptable uh but
you know people people joke about you
know people outside of their ethnicity
um kind of you all of you look the same
to me right this this is not something
that we're allowed to do anymore and yet
we all know that there's a little bit of
Truth in if you are a member of an
ethnicity with with whom I have um very
little exposure uh at first it may be
true that I am less likely to be able to
tell members of your ethnicity apart
than members of my own because I have
more experience telling members of my
own ethnicity apart well look I'm uh you
know at the risk of being cancelled over
it I'm going to admit that I have this
very issue uh with
antifa yeah that might have to do with
the uh the cloaking device that they use
right but they all do it and then it's
you know hopeless to tell who's who I'm
not all that interested in telling who's
who but if that's one of the reasons
Andy no is doing such a
service yes he has uh he has decloaked
them yeah yeah but um but no so you have
to be able to tell individuals apart in
order to be social and
um you know it's being able to S
individuals apart can allow you to be
cooperative can allow you to be to be
social can also um allow you to
recognize and this is just from the
paper that I'm about to be talking about
some other reasons that it might be good
to be able to recognize individuals um
understanding where individuals are in a
dominance hierarchy like if you can't
tell if you if you exist in a dominance
hierarchy and you can't tell who anyone
else is you're constantly going to be
going up to individuals and um doing the
wrong thing and either um seating a
dominant position that you could have
had because um because you are
responding badly or um getting clocked
uh because you are uh engaging with
someone who is actually higher in the
dominance hierarchy uh you need to be
able to tell individuals apart in order
to um and this was this was in the paper
and because one of our sons is uh here
as our producer I thought I'd just uh
read the phrase uh verbatim allocating
parental care efficiently um so if you
can't tell your kids apart um and one of
them has already gotten a lot of food
you want to be able you might continue
to give them food and not the other one
cutting back to the front of line
cutting back to the front of the line so
you need to be able to tell your kids
apart in order to make sure that they
all get uh equal treatment if if that's
what you want to give them and of course
there are cases where people don't uh
and then um telling Neighbors from
Intruders when engaging in territorial
defense so these are all just examples
from um non-human organisms where
research has been done and demonstrated
there is advantage in recognizing
individuals but of course all of these
apply to humans as well so the question
then is how do we do it how do we tell
individuals apart and um we no doubt use
many many senses uh we use chemical
senses we can smell uh differences uh
and and vulmer nasal as well sort of
larger the larger form of
ofaction uh we detect people by the
sound of their voices uh The Voice
people can definitely recognize people
by sound in fact I had a couple people
approach me while we were traveling
recently and say I didn't recognize you
but once I heard your voice I I
recognized you um and also of course we
have we have language so we have names
and uh and in uh in social media we're
often restricted to uh very few of these
signals but there will be like a little
image and a name and um and we can use
that but of course as primates most of
what we do is visual most of what we do
is Visual and um that's in part because
although mammals are um largely
olfactory in terms of our dominant sense
primates have moved to having our eyes
in the front we've got frontation uh and
now we can do you know binocular vision
uh and we've got this expansion of the
part of our brain um that focuses on
vision and so we are really highly uh
visually
attuned um and we will tend primates
will tend to recognize each other on the
basis of visual cues Birds though not so
much uh even though um birds have um
these elaborate displays these sexual
selection displays um when it has been
looked at when people have investigated
um on what basis individual recognition
happens in species of birds it's often
auditory and so like there's there's
some parrots that actually have
different um effectively different names
for their offspring they use different
vocalizations for different ones of
their offspring uh and um and in general
birds are are known to cue off of
different teners different songs in
different um or tambers in uh in
different individuals so I would just
point out that you could infer a lot of
that um from the fact that parrots are
obviously trainable to get to make human
like vocalizations which tells you that
they have the Discrimination capacity to
detect these little differences so not
surprising that that CA would be um
particularly um sensitive to subtle
differences between individuals
vocalizations exactly uh so you can just
show this picture briefly Zach these are
some African penguins who were the
subject of uh some new re research just
published in animal
behavior um just hanging out walking I
guess they're walking um and they kind
of all look alike is um but probably
even um even humans who aren't um
necessarily that good at telling
Penguins apart which is to say most of
us uh can quickly see some differences
between these different individuals what
what do you see well I see different
patterns of dots now are those dots is
that in the the the feathers or have
they splattered themselves with
something nope that's plumage that's
plumage yeah those are DOT differences
across the chests of these penguins yeah
and uh this species um is noticeably
enough variable with regard to the
pattern of these dots on their chests uh
that these
researchers again published in animal
behavior um recently and then reported
on in science um specifically went and
looked at whether or not uh individuals
were telling each other apart by the by
virtue of the
dots and um actually uh Zach would you
just show the little video of the setup
of the experiment and then I'll EXP
explain what's going on because the
video's kind of kind of
cute and I think there's no sound for
this so I'll just say for those uh for
people just listening uh you've got a a
penguin who has been encouraged away
from his group into a little pen that is
then closed behind him and in the pen he
finds two pictures and I don't know if
that was a he or a she uh two pictures
of penguins and uh then as is so often
the case with Choice experiments um uh
the the amount of time that the penguin
spents orienting towards and then
approaching and spending time and
proximity towards one of the images is
uh is what is measured and is considered
you know that that that image um that
the that the subject of the experiment
spends most time orienting towards and
closest to is what is considered the
preference so uh what are the pictures
this bird is looking at you have
something to say well I'm wondering if
if it was the dots in the uh in the page
well but they did a number of things in
the right term uh I don't know I don't
know
feathers feathers certainly Works um so
they they did they did what we just saw
and this is from a captive Colony uh and
there were six um six monogamous pairs
in this Colony interestingly five
heterosexual pairs one male homosexual
pair and then at least one um uh
individual who's not paired up in this
colony and so they took these six pairs
and uh and for each of the 12
individuals in them uh they did a number
uh they did a number of choice tests
they showed um so this is this a captive
Colony yeah as I as I said yeah sorry um
so they've and it's and it's relatively
small right uh so uh in one of the uh
choices they show just a picture of the
partner versus some other member of The
Colony unchanged the entire body visible
uh with that experiment uh the
individual always prefers the partner
okay so therefore there is some visual
cue for sure right they're not just
using uh vocalization or smell or
something if they can see a picture and
prefer to be with the partner they're
using they're using Vision somewhat uh
they have another experiment in which uh
there's actually five but I'm only going
to talk about four here um five
experiments um the second one is they've
got an unaltered picture of the uh
partner uh showing the dots and the
whole body and then they've got an
altered picture of this of the same
individual the partner but in which the
dots have been
cleared and uh in that choice test uh
the individuals always prefer their
unaltered partner as opposed to the
partner with the dots gone okay that
doesn't necessarily tell us anything on
its own uh because maybe having no dots
at all just feels like I don't even know
who that is it tells you that they are
registering the dots right um there's a
third experiment in which they've got um
partner versus nonp partner but in both
of the cases all the dots have been
removed so maybe there are other cues
that they're looking at and maybe the
dots don't matter um but when
individuals are exposed to those all
body shots partner nonp partner but no
dots there's no preference they show no
preference at all and then the fourth
experiment which had a a a clear result
uh they've got partner versus nonp
partner and only the head is visible uh
so they're only showing the head and
again no preference interesting that
suggests that they're definitely using
the dots yep it does not rule out the
possibility of other visual cues such as
what if so these were all static
pictures yes so they didn't register
what if you know how you can tell who
somebody is by the way they even if
you're not close enough to see who they
are about the way they walk sure so if
they maybe the way these penguins run MH
could be a Quee meaning that it would be
a matter of dots and dashes oh
no I mean you will grant me that not
only is that a decent pun but it's also
a valid scientific point and so that's
not all that common yeah so you think
part of underneath your hypoth your pun
there is the hypothesis that they're
communicating in Morse code exactly
exactly yeah well uh I have the
communicating author's email here if you
want to just email I think it was a her
uh and uh I feel like sending them this
observation in Morse code yes and
anonymously
perhaps you know perhaps maybe that
would be wise yeah um but I mean that's
that's the research and I thought um
both both thought that the experiments
themselves were elegant and uh and
really going down the line um tell you
something real about what these what
these penguins are paying attention to
um and it's also just a an excuse to
speak you know when when we were
professors when I used to teach Animal
Behavior Uh before I would talk about
kin selection before I would talk about
sexual selection before I would talk
about the evolution of sex and why sex
is binary and all of these things um I
would always spend time first on but in
order for um almost all of the interest
interesting stuff we're about to be
talking about to work you have to be
able to recognize Who's Who and this is
such just a a basic thing about Humanity
you know primates can recognize who's
who I assume I doubt that the research
has explicitly been done in every
primate species um but I assume that all
primates can recognize individuals
within at least a family group um they
can tell them apart yeah I think the
only questions would be
uh certain
pmans you know mostly solitary pmans but
I agree with you I bet you
um I bet you that they can all tell them
apart and you know guess I mean with mic
cbus for example which is the mouse
lemur it's um they're nocturnal also tar
seers um bush babies but micrus mous
lemur of which I think there are a
couple of species but um we saw them
when I was working in Madagascar and
um and I believe correct me if you have
a different memory of this um that you
caught some on photographically on what
at that point was film um and because we
were kind of following them around at
night we ended up feeling like actually
it seems like these guys are monogamous
oh yeah and I think that my memory is um
that at least was not um really being
reported in literature at that point
like they were they were believed to be
solitary right and we when we found them
which was not a lot but when we found
them you just takes a lot of work at
night and and everything but um I don't
know if we ever found one without seeing
another one close by and seeing to what
to our eyes looked like them
communicating vocally between one
another yeah I mean we were obviously in
one spot and uh a lot of it was um in a
unique situation cuz we were on a tiny
little island off the coast so it may
have been you know two pairs right but
it was the experience that one often has
with Stellar's Jays you see a Stellar's
jayates you almost always see another um
and in fact one will look out and uh
make noises if something dangerous a cat
for example yeah comes by so you know
you see one but if you look for a second
you'll see it true with many squirrels
yep um loons which we now have migrating
through here if you see one if you look
carefully there's almost always another
one somewhere um so that did have that
kind of implication but the question is
if you were a micrus uh and you're in
the dark well maybe you recognize your
partner visually but it might be that
you recognize the other members of the
population uh fact right it doesn't need
to be visual um there's you know like
individual recognition can be across as
I as I lay out like any of these senses
and indeed you know we've taking it to
an an additional cultural level of
having associating ourselves with names
and right and you know and gate is not
at the sensory level it's I mean I don't
even know what to call that um in terms
of the modality like it's not a sensory
modality but for sure I would think that
the Penguins dashing yeah and the humans
walking across you know in a particular
way that you can you can detect people
um by their walk um often even from a
distance totally and uh we are all
familiar if you have a dog that dogs
detect who they're dealing with uh
olfactorily because of course all dogs
look alike I mean unless you're very
very
careful dogs also don't get offended
very easily I have had trouble offending
them with words I don't think I mean all
dogs I I don't think that's the way to
offend her if you want to offend the
dogs you say I just I can't tell you
guys apart yeah yeah no I was just I was
kidding because uh dogs are the only
creature I think they vastly exceed
human variation in morphology within
species because of what we've done to
them under domestication but um they
certainly are highly variable they are
highly variable but I mean I think I
think the point here is um that so are
all all
organisms uh even the ones that aren't
social that don't have individual
recognition but the ones that do you
know what is it what are the cues that
they are using and in the case of these
a African penguins they're using those
uh adorable dots on their chests yeah uh
and it does raise the question uh you
know you asked when you first saw that
picture is that is that plumage or is
that you know mud splatter yeah uh do
they become less easy to tell apart for
other Penguins after they've been
walking in the mud yeah I don't know
could could be and and are they more uh
inclined to clean themselves off because
it's
confusing um by the way I don't think
all animals differ within species
substantially I don't think gats I
didn't say substantially I said there's
going to be some variation I think even
gats don't care I didn't say that all in
animals have individual recognition I
said there's variation between
individuals yeah I was just I was just
kidding I'm not even disagreeing with
you I just think um if I was in that I
wouldn't care I mean it's it's a
very yeah I think most animals don't
care yep I don't know what we're talking
about that'ss mostly okay um so that's
that's what I had I wanted to talk about
uh penguin dots and their ability to
tell each other apart based on their
dots cool well that's exciting um so
tell me more the African penguin this is
presumably South
Africa I guess so yeah I did not I did
not pursue the particular any anything
more about the particular species
involved yeah I would think so um we of
course ran into penguins in galopagos
where they are seem distinctly out of
place because of how warm it is there um
yeah now the galpagos penguins are
utterly delightful and um I know a lot
of people have a particular love for
Penguins My Mother Does for instance um
and I have not um I'd never you know
never been anywhere I could have seen
them in person and didn't feel a
particular um fondness for them I didn't
dislike them I just didn't feel a
particular fondness for them but
snorkeling in galpagos and having three
Penguins Circle me and come up to my
mask and then swim away and come up to
my mask again uh was one of the
highlights of Life honestly it was
completely fantastic it's pretty cool
yeah having penguins come right up to
you and sort of look at you and maybe
what were they thinking was where are
your dots yeah exactly yeah although
those Penguins I I have this picture
which is actually pretty good but I
don't like it CU it looks like they're
in a zoo the sand is so uniform that it
looks like I've taken a picture of a
penguin in a zoo rather than this is a
wild animal um you know they're kind of
uh unlike the rest of that Clay they're
much muddier in
coloration theh version yeah all right
well um I hope we haven't antagonized
people I know penguins are very
polarizing people feel very black and
white about them yeah they keep on
imagining they're in the north uh
Northern Hemisphere and they're just not
right it's hard it's hard to uh migrate
that far when it's a matter of waddling
all right I think you wanted to talk
about something
else PE Prosperity yes all right so we
are at uh the Final Phase here I wanted
to alert people that I am participating
in a three-part Peak Prosperity
Extravaganza um called prospering with
Integrity um and and if people want to
find out about it they can go to Peak
that's P
a.fan
fn/ integrity and they can see the
three-part
series um if they want
to uh participate in it um it will be um
me Peter St an I think that's how you
pronounce his name Ed Dow and Chris
Martinson um will be doing a a
three-part deep dive in more or less uh
where the world is why uh things are
moving in the direction they are and
what might be properly done about it
there is a discount code for Darkhorse
viewers it is Darkhorse 25 that gets you
25% off the uh the price of admission
you can choose to do one of the three
sessions if you want or you could do a
bundle of all three the code works for
either and if you want to save even more
you can join our uh locals Community as
a supporter and there is a code for
substantially more than that off so
anyway that's a good reason to join us
on locals and whether or not you have
joined us on locals um join us on the
Peak Prosperity 3 part webinar when is
it that is a great question 9th is the
first one December the first okay so you
got you got time you got time and then
it's separated by a week or like we
don't I don't know yet okay so it for
starts on December 9th but you can join
you can join now uh to get access you
can join our locals now to get the code
yep and uh just you can uh Chris has a
video in which he describes the uh
intended activities but I will just say
that one of the things that we're going
to do is we're going to div divide into
two teams one of the teams is going to
Steelman the position of the Elites in
all of their um their Liberty destroying
Glory we are going to take their
position are you going to draw straws to
figure out who's on what team um no
there is a part of me that's sort of
hoping to be on the uh the steel Manning
the elites team I think I might do a
good job of that um and uh anyway that
could be kind of fun so there it is I
think it's going to be great um Chris uh
runs a tight ship and U many of you saw
him on the Dark Horse podcast or maybe
you saw me on the Peak Prosperity
podcast but anyway um he's a great guy
and uh with him spearheading this it
can't
miss awesome uh Zach do you want to just
show the store once more before we sign
off do that yeah um so um I think Brett
you need to just reintroduce Jake's
micro pizza because I've been hearing
about it from people uh and I'm not
there it is Jake's micro Pizza uh you
want to talk about how awesome it is
Jake's micro Pizza is the best pizza
you've ever tasted or your money back it
is um it is actually zero calorie and
that's not because we use low calorie
ingredients is because the slices of
pizza are so small that they don't have
even a substant stantial fraction of a
calorie so you can just keep eating them
and one of the collateral benefit yes
you are looking at me a scance that's
not the way actual calories work that is
how the FDA no that is how the FDA views
calories so but we're using the FDA
standards now um this is because I don't
know if I'm on board with that well
let's put it to you this way yeah if I
say uh how many calories are there in
one serving of uh some delicious uh
organic figs right okay we don't do
fractional calories we do round yes I
understand and this is why the FDA does
what it does right but uh if uh you say
there's no calories in one serving that
does not mean that there's no calories
in a thousand servings the rounding oh
that's not what I'm saying oh I'm not
cheating like that I am saying that
these these pieces of pizza are actually
so small that actually nobody has
figured out how many of them you would
have to eat before you would go from
zero calorie to one calorie and that's
not for lack of effort on their part uh
it may difficulty finding them again
they're very very small but um they what
what problem does Jake's micro Pizza
solve Brett two problems yes um uh if
you feel like having a snack
I don't think it does solve that problem
no um okay not wait wait wait okay no I
grant you it doesn't Solve IT addresses
that problem without solving it okay
fair enough fair enough uh what problem
does it solve well I don't know I have
noticed that when I've been enjoying
Jake's micro Pizza that um had there
been a mask mandate this would have
temporarily freed me from it until I was
done eating and they are so small that
there's really no reason to be done
eating you can just always be eating
Jake's micro pizza and uh if you're not
a fan of mask mandates this could in
some incidental way free you from having
to abide by one I mean you would be
abiding by one because you'd be eating
and we all know that mask mandates do
not apply when you're eating so get
yourself a uh carton of Jake's micro
pizza and a shirt to explain to others
why you don't have your mask on very
good yes
precisely okay uh yeah we've got a lot
of cool stuff there on the website do
not affirm do not comply um epic Tabby
all that um go there uh find cool stuff
and um there will be I think another
guest episode coming out before we see
you next yes on Sat hopefully um soon
and um join us on locals
join join us I don't know what's
happened to the screen here um join us
all sorts of cool places um and we will
be back next week same time same place
and follow up the live stream with a
short episode on um on possible gifts
along with uh a can I say it a playlist
that you are generating right yep I feel
like you did it yep so why do you look
scared I'm
not nothing's scared about me all right
um so we we'll get back to that next
week and uh remember that we are
supported by you we are grateful to you
we appreciate you subscribing and liking
and sharing what we do and until we see
you next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well and enjoy Jake's micro
Pizza
[Music]